in the world of big tech we often hear
about billions of customers last year
for example apple crossed 1 billion
active iphone users similarly google
also boasts 1 billion active users but
by far the biggest is facebook who has
nearly 3 billion active users
considering these mind-boggling numbers
and the fact that these companies are
basically ubiquitous it's not surprising
that these companies are valued in the
trillions but what does surprise me
though are the background tech companies
that the average person has never heard
of such companies generally serve
corporate customers and have little need
to appeal to ordinary people yet they
boast market caps in the hundreds of
billions and one of the best examples of
this is salesforce
in 2017 salesforce announced that they
have more than 150 000 customers
even if we assume that this number has
grown to 200 000 customers given that
salesforce is valued at 228 billion
dollars each customer is worth well over
a million dollars in terms of market cap
to put that in perspective each facebook
customer is only worth 225 dollars worth
of market cap and even each apple
customer is only worth 2 800 worth of
market cap so here's what salesforce
does and how they became one of the most
lucrative businesses in the world
taking a look back the story of
salesforce dates back to a man named
mark benioff who was born on september
25th 1964 in san francisco california
mark's father owned a local department
store in san francisco which provided a
family with a pretty comfortable life
but mark's father refused to spoil mark
he felt that mark should work for
everything he wanted so when mark wanted
a computer as a teenager his father told
him to go get a job mark ended up being
a janitor at a jewelry store but
unfortunately this didn't last too long
as mark would be fired for using the
wrong soap on the floors fortunately
though he was able to save up enough
money to buy a computer most kids
nowadays want a computer to play games
but mark actually wanted a computer to
develop games mark started off small by
developing an application called how to
juggle which he would sell for 75
but once he saw this first paycheck he
would go all in on game development at
15 he founded a one-man company called
liberty software which developed games
for the atari 8-bit over the next year
he published dozens of games including
flapper king arthur's hair the nightmare
escaped from vulcan's isle and crypt of
the undead he worked with a company
called epics to bring his games to
market and by the time he was 16 he was
earning 1500 a month just from royalties
adjusting for inflation that's over 5
000 per month today so mark was
basically making 60 000 per year as a 16
year old and it's no wonder why this guy
became a billionaire
anyway mark ended up attending the
university of southern california where
he majored in business administration
while completing his bachelor's mark
took on internships as a programmer at
apple's macintosh division mark enjoyed
this experience and wanted to continue
his journey as a programmer but one of
his university professors advised that
customer-oriented work would be much
more beneficial for mark so mark got a
sales job at oracle after graduation
while sales was not mark's area of
expertise he stand here as well
just one year after joining mark was
named oracle's rookie of the year at age
23 and just three years after that mark
became the youngest person in the
company's history to become vice
president considering the massive
salaries of executives mark was able to
become a millionaire by the time he was
25 mark could have easily stayed at
oracle and possibly even worked his way
up the ceo but after 13 years at oracle
he decided that he wanted to do
something bigger mark felt that all
software companies were approaching
software incorrectly they treated
software as a product every few years
companies like adobe and microsoft came
out with a new version of windows or
photoshop but mark felt that it would be
way better if these companies treated
software as a service and constantly
provided updates along the way
given that this is basically what all
software companies do today mark was
clearly on to something and in february
of 1999 he would start trying to make
this vision a reality by launching
salesforce
mark didn't try to start salesforce by
himself though he brought with them
three oracle veterans named parker
harris dave molinov and frank dominguez
initially larry ellison oracle's founder
was extremely supportive of mark
starting his own business
in fact he funded the startup with 2
million and even became a board member
but when he realized that salesforce was
also trying to compete against oracle
larry stopped helping salesforce but he
did keep his stake
now that's all cool and all but what
exactly does salesforce even do
well the bread and butter of salesforce
is customer relationship management or
crm software crm software allows
companies to aggregate all of their
sales marketing and customer service
data into one easy to use platform this
makes it much easier for companies to
analyze their demographic in extreme
detail for example what's your
conversion rate how many unique
customers do you have how many customers
are repeat customers how do sales vary
with the age and location of your
customers and so on and so forth
companies can then turn around and use
this data to address shortfalls single
out certain demographics and craft
targeted marketing campaigns that are
super effective so basically crm
software takes care of the logistics of
managing customer data now providing crm
solutions wasn't a new idea by any means
there were already plenty of large
companies already providing crm
solutions like oracle and microsoft but
as we previously touched on these guys
were selling the software as a product
customers had to buy the software every
few years install it onto their
computers and servers store all the data
themselves and troubleshoot many issues
themselves but with salesforce
salesforce will store the data
salesforce will run the servers and
salesforce will run the software
customers simply had to use a web portal
to access everything they needed from
anywhere in the world the convenience
and accessibility that salesforce
provided were unbeatable but there were
a few concerns first of all companies
had to trust salesforce with customer
data and secondly this was not a
one-time purchase it was a subscription
but as more and more corporations
switched over to salesforce companies
had easier time trusting salesforce but
it wasn't all smooth sailing like all
tech companies that were founded before
2000 salesforce had to navigate the
dot-com crash and this was particularly
rough given that salesforce was an
extremely young company when the bubble
burst to ease the financial stress on
the company marked sales first public in
june of 2004 which allowed them to raise
110 million dollars this helped them
survive the dot-com crash but mark knew
that he had to diversify their income in
order to better weather future
recessions
one of mark's first diversification
efforts came in 2005 when salesforce
introduced app exchange as the name
suggests app exchange was basically an
app store but for businesses salesforce
customers could download these apps and
salesforce would split the revenue with
the app developers
now this probably doesn't sound that
crazy today but keep in mind that this
was years before the iphone app store
another diversification effort from
salesforce came in 2009 with the launch
of the service cloud similar to app
exchange service cloud was another
corporate application of an everyday
service if you have a technical question
one of the first things you'll probably
do is google it but it's not so easy if
you're a company and have a question
about databases or servers so with
service cloud mark basically launched a
google slash quora type service for
corporations similarly in 2011 mark
launched chatter which was a social
collaboration service for companies all
these diversification efforts did help
salesforce's top line as revenue
exploded from hundreds of millions to
billions per year but salesforce's
bottom line wasn't looking that great
because salesforce was reinvesting all
of their profits into their employees
and acquisitions the acquisition part is
self-explanatory but for people who
aren't familiar with salesforce they
probably aren't aware of salesforce's
insane salaries software engineers for
example earn anywhere between 182 000 to
754 000 per year similarly managers earn
anywhere between 248 000 to 1 million
dollars per year at salesforce you can
literally earn a seven figure salary
without being a c-suite executive
considering these salaries i don't think
you'd be surprised to hear that
salesforce is the ninth highest paying
company in the world aside from high
salaries salesforce has one of the best
workplaces in the world with salesforce
boasting an a-plus in terms of workplace
culture even apollo only scores a b-plus
this has earned salesforce the title of
second best place to work for in the
world according to fortune mark also
ranks as the 15th most approved ceo in
the us by employees so clearly mark knew
what he was doing and turning a profit
simply wasn't the priority for him he
wanted to get salesforce's holdings
diversification and employees to a
certain level of satisfaction before
focusing on profits and in 2016 this
time had finally come and ever since
then salesforce has not only been
pulling in billions every year but
keeping billions
today salesforce serves 90 of the
fortune 500 including everyone from
apple and facebook to walmart and
mastercard and the given that each of
these guys pay salesforce millions of
dollars per year if not tens of millions
for their services it's not surprising
that salesforce pulled in 25 billion
revenue in the most recent 12-month
period aside from being a giant within
the corporate world salesforce practices
what mark calls the 1-1-1 philanthropy
model every year salesforce dedicates
one percent of the company's equity one
percent of their products and one
percent of their employees time to
philanthropic efforts so far salesforce
has given their software to 46 000
non-profits and ngos for free or at a
discount and their employees have
volunteered for a total of 4.9 million
hours as for mark he only owns a modest
three to four percent of the company but
given the size of salesforce that itself
translates to nine billion dollars mark
of course enjoys wealth by splurging on
toys like mansions and cars but mark
also donates significant amounts of his
wealth he's a very large proponent of
taking action against climate change in
fact just a couple of months ago he
donated 300 million dollars to fight
climate change 200 million of this came
from mark himself and 100 million came
from salesforce also do you guys
remember the tmp's effort from mr beast
a couple of years ago mr beast was able
to raise a total of 23 million dollars
which translates to 23 million trees
being planted there were some high
profile figures who donated to team
trees one of them being mark who donated
900 thousand dollars not only did mark
donate to team trees but he went ahead
and launched his own tree planting
foundation called 1t.org as the name
suggests the goal of the foundation is
to plant 1 trillion trees by 2050 and
given the connections that mark has he
has been able to get over 300 companies
on board so hopefully this vision does
become a reality but we'll just have to
wait and see do you guys think mark can
plant one trillion trees comment that
down below also drop a like if you hope
mark succeeds and of course consider
checking out our international channels
to watch our videos in other languages
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
next one